hey you guys it's the weekend which
means it's movie reviewing time once
again yeah this is a cool movie I wanted
to recommend to our regular listeners
this was called the Omega Man and of
course it has the hats in it the hats is
those who you do not know who the
hatched is the cast is also known as
Moses or aka Charlton Heston
Moses was Charlton Heston Charlton
Heston wasn't Lois
yeah that's I I never said state that's
out yeah this is awesome flick I first
saw this and I was a little kid and it
came on TV and I wasn't really sure what
I was watching and I didn't really know
what a mutant was or what biological
warfare was this must been around 75 -
aw that's prob about six and to me it
was just like a scary vampire movie with
this guy running around in a car with a
submachine gun and that was all I needed
to know it was just awesome awesome
movie but seeing that recently I just
just bought the DVD to add to my
collection and the comment for some
chick let some chick on our last video
saying nobody watches DVDs everybody
streams so now I have a DD I have a
blu-ray collection I like to own
something physical if it's like a
favorite movie tech you yeah if it's one
that you're gonna watch over and over
again and yeah you like to have a
physical copy I don't wanna sisters and
[ __ ] on it yes yeah I want a physical
product and yeah I want to cover I look
at the back side I want all the you know
the bullets Beach probably do that for
movies I'm super super in yeah I don't
have like a [ __ ] ton of DVDs or blu-rays
or anything like that but I have kind of
you know several dozen that are like my
favorite movies that I just liked it I
just like to have the kind of a pride
and ownership but of course you know we
got a home theater with it you know yeah
that big surround sound system and
everything so you know I just like to
rock it same way tell us about the movie
Jay well the Omega Man obviously came
out in 1971 this was kind of like
Charlton Heston's sci-fi period he'd
also been implanted the Apes and he was
a couple years later he's also in
Soylent Green yeah another good one yeah
and these are kind of like a similar
sort of theme probably everybody knows
but the movie is actually a loose
adaptation of the 1954 Richard Matheson
I am Legend yeah now I am Legend had
been made into a movie before in 1964
and the movie was called the last man on
earth it was made in Italy and it
starred Vincent Price yeah we saw it
it's a good movie actually you know and
I have to say of all the adaptations of
the novel none of them are really that
close to the book the last man on earth
is the closest yeah it's pretty cool
yeah and it's still not the same there's
still like a lot of differences but it's
actually the closest version and also a
fun fact the Richard Matheson novel I am
Legend which was essentially a vampire
novel sort of but the way that it was
that it's story came across and the way
the movie the last man on earth came
across the vampires were actually more
zombie like yeah and George Romero has
cited the Richard Matheson novel as his
inspiration for Night of the Living Dead
he said his first screenplay version of
the movie was pretty much a ripoff of
the novel so really I am Legend I guess
can be credited with being the sort of
thing that kicked off the entire modern
zombie genre right because you know it's
and it's very obvious if you see the
last minute earth I mean you will see
how the influence played out on George
Romero and how the zombie thing happened
but in the book they were vampires
they weren't supernatural they were
actually it was you know caused by a
plague but it gave them the outward
appearance of vampires like they were
sunlight you know they couldn't go out
in the Sun they crave blood and stuff
like that and because of cultural
expectations they were also like afraid
of crosses and garlic and stuff like
that
yeah and if you saw I am Legend starring
what's-his-name Will Smith and you think
that you've read the book I am Legend or
you've seen the Omega man just because
you've seen Will Smith I am Legend
you're absolutely wrong Will Smith I am
led to this is it basically a complete
abomination it pretty much is and
actually I've heard and I haven't seen
it but I think in 2007-2008 they also
made a made-for-tv movie called I am
Omega which is based on the book but
doesn't credit it which really classy
that's something I gotta say
yes that was bad yeah it got pretty
mixed reviews from it essentially seemed
like I mean and like the Will Smith
version yeah that was essentially just a
zombie it was like 28 days later except
not good ok now we're just talking about
the Omega Man the movie all right now a
Mega Man the movie here here's the
premise it's basically a
post-apocalyptic movie where there's
only one man left in LA and he's being
attacked by I guess you could say like a
cult of vampires
yeah all right although I don't think
they ever called them vampire No there
you go I do I like you find out later
that they're kind of scientifically
plausible vampires their muse
they were mutated by a biological weapon
created by the air force and Charlton
Heston plays a guy named Neville and
Neville was working on the cure for that
biological agent he was the only man
that actually received an experimental
serum and that's why he's that's why
he's still he's still alive and he is no
no you didn't need to meet me so it's a
pretty cool flick you know he spends a
lot of times going through abandoned
hotels abandoned theatres he's got his
house rigged up like this huge well one
of the one of the black vampires calls
it a hockey paradise yeah it's pretty
cool since Neville's house was this
brownstone building that he turned into
a fortress basically it's got machine
guns on the roof it's got barbed wire
lights because the Jews can't stand
light yeah that's right now yeah when
they mutate they turn into albinos
psychopathic white-eyed albinos yes
they're being led by a guy named
Matthias who used to be a news reporter
and he's taken over
it looks like City Hall in LA and all of
his followers are living there and
they're and what they do is is they have
this cult that runs around the city at
night burning down libraries and
anything that's technological so because
Neville basically is using technology
they see him as
a heretic and a relic from the past and
he's like on their listed
list of to do things a there they're
trying to kill him they're shitless yeah
he's on the [ __ ] list and Neville in the
meantime just grab some of them and did
experiments on them to try to cure them
and that didn't work so Neville spends a
lot of his time trying to hunt down
where the nest is and and figure out
ways to kill so now unfortunately in
this movie they don't really show his
his war of extermination against it's
just kind of referred to they just refer
to it yeah he's already kind of like
this legendary villain in the minds of
these mutes mutants slash vampires and
essentially that's kind of one of the
things that like I said in a lot of ways
yes this is based on the Richard
Matheson novel but it takes a lot of
liberties with the with the core story
in the book the vampires are pretty much
just vampires they're kind of feral
there are a few later on that you find
out that are intelligent and are
starting to starting a new society and
things like that in this the mutants are
super intelligent but for some reason
like after they become mutated by this
biological weapon they also I don't know
if there are other ones that don't want
to join the culture if you just
automatically though they join the cult
it's said that they all become
Psychopaths Neville said that they'd be
a psychopath so basically they're going
back to the Middle Ages because they
have this perception that it was
technology and modern things that caused
this Cataclysm the rush so they're gonna
take it back old school and so they
still do attack Neville but they can't
they don't use guns they don't use any
modern weapons they use just all pretty
much yes fire trebuchet yeah you know
California's [ __ ] like beers one guy
cheats and tries to use a pistol but you
know he was really desperate you're
still looking at him they look and they
kind of have the feel of vampires yeah
like medieval vampires yeah and these
medieval like what do you call it like
the Inquisition kind of a yeah they're
like yeah they're monkish monk looking
and at one point they do capture Neville
and they're gonna burn him at the stake
yeah and they crucify little kids and
stuff when you watch a movie yeah
there's like there's a really lot of
Christian symbolism in this which is
like super super obvious yeah um you
know some might say heavy-handed I don't
think it was kind of like a warped
vampiric version of yeah of Christianity
yeah not so much
Christianity but more of like a vampiric
version of the Inquisition
yes anti-technology Inquisition yes
similar kind of thing right and another
thing that's ringing him because this
movie was made in 1971 there's also a
lot of [ __ ] about like counterculture
versus you know the old guard and stuff
like that with I guess Charlton Heston
representing the you know the old guard
perhaps and you know that they they have
a character also who's named Lisa and
she's kind of like a very stereotypical
blaxploitation yes Black Power chick
kind of chick with an afro Norton like
that and so there's kind of that element
as well and then there's also the scene
where Charlton Heston is like he goes in
the movie theater I guess he goes like
pretty much every day or every other day
and the only movie that's playing is
what was that because that's what was
playing when the end of the world came
so he's just watched it over and over
and he had like memorized so there's
kind of that underlying current as well
which I don't think was actually
intended from the outset but the husband
and wife that wrote the script they
thought it would be interesting to add
this kind of culture clash element to it
yeah interestingly I think this is one
of the first interracial kisses wing
down well the first interracial kiss was
Star Trek wasn't it I think it was just
on television yeah it wasn't preheat
predated it but it was Whoopi Goldberg
once said that it was one of the first
it's case of what it's got to be one of
the Persians and you know I'm sure
people flick flick either and season
always happen in some kind of
apocalyptic movie or some kind of
futuristic movie you know Apocalypse
that's good that's a good excuse to get
a black girlfriend well that's alright
no one else got dude he's gonna do and
that's what
tell your friends you know they compare
with the another world you know I have
to get some black buoys that's you know
that was just they needed back to it
Charlton Heston was Alexei and the
shadow is just like where's another
planets in the future its aliens it's
fine everyone's fine with I already did
I mean I have to say we're gonna
probably disagree on this but of all the
adaptations of I am Legend like I said I
haven't seen the TV one I've heard it
wasn't that good and it doesn't really
sound that good and the fact that they
didn't credit the book kind of pisses me
off
you know I'm gonna say the last one on
earth is actually my favorite adaptation
because it it Hughes closest to the nose
closest to the book oh man like I said
seems like it kind of goes its own way
yeah I kind of consider Heston's Omega
Man to be its own thing it's kind of its
own its own thing and I really like the
movie for that yeah it's more of a
post-apocalyptic movie and it has a kind
of a bio warfare yeah theme to it and a
vampire theme to it run on it once last
man on earth was good it was really good
it was more kind of like a zombie movie
a little more like neither Living Dead
but it it did stay closer to the book as
yeah as far as I know the book I'm read
the book because really that's what
they're both good they're definitely
both and I think that I mean the book in
the Omega Man actually have two really
different messages I mean I think the
Omega Man was kind of more like Charlton
Heston and he was a scientist and he had
come up with the vaccine or actually in
the end his blood ends up being used as
a vaccine and he's kind of like you know
wiping out the he wants to wipe out the
mutants and get humanity back on track
and like you know help everybody get
back to the thing whereas the point of
the book was that these vampires were
actually like a new race of people run
and Neville was the last human being
yeah that wasn't in fact
and he was just going around killing all
these you know new race of people yeah
therefore he was the monster run so I
mean hence the title I am Legend because
he's like a boogeyman you're right they
were all afraid of him he was just like
he was like the last remnant of an old
society that was gone now that was still
trying to terrorize the new people now
there's a lost scene to the Omega Man
and I've only heard of it you nobody's
seen it you know at least not nobody in
modern times is where Lisa goes to the
cemetery yeah that's right all right to
tell her parents her to visit her her
parents who have been dead you know of
course know their tombs and it turns out
she's pregnant with Neville's baby
that's right yeah
and while she's there she sees one of
the mutants alright from the family a
girl who's mourning the loss of a
newborn child so she sees that and
assumes that her child would be born
dead too yeah because it doesn't have
the immunity and he she goes back and
tells Nevin Neville that she saw one of
the family members or the mutants you
know with a dead baby
and he asked her well you know basically
did you kill her judge no what do you
tell me should have kill her
but she's like you know Who am I to kill
her when I might be in the same her
shoes a few days we have her a few
months from now when the baby's born and
then he comforts her you know he's like
yeah I didn't think about that but that
soon that scene was deleted but in the
credits you see woman and cemetery lists
and that's what they're talking about
now I'm kind of there was a good scene
there like I want to see actually I kind
of wish they have left that happen
because it would have introduced a lot
of moral ambiguity that I don't think
was really there in the movie I mean in
the movie it's pretty obvious that the
mutants are bad guys yeah well they'll
kill you on sight
that's why I mean they're crazy you know
whereas in the book and in the last man
on earth it's left a lot more ambiguous
like who's the bad guy is Neville the
bad guy are the other people bad guy you
know what I mean or are they the same as
each other and I think they kind of got
rid of that for then which probably is
why they took that scene out cuz they
said well maybe that's just kind of
muddies the waters know we don't really
want to do that
you know we want Charles Nesson be a
good guy it's a classic flick if you
have the Senate go go read it I think
you can you can read it on YouTube it's
David okay especially the action the
action is it has choreography along the
lines of maybe a couple notches above us
Star Trek or is it is a cool movie to
watch yeah I'd say that I really liked
the scenes with him that were running
around the daytime on that baby blue
mustang with that Smith & Wesson
submachine gun shooting at people
running by the windows that's pretty
yeah the ending scene the climax of it
what wasn't quite done to say 1980s type
specs you know I mean if this was movie
had we're done in the 80s it would it
would have I think had a little more of
a fiery shootout at the end that let you
know yeah this is an end but the way
this one ends it's kind of like yeah you
know Lisa lets the she lets the vampires
into his apartment to capture him he
grabs an mp40 he shoots his way out of
there he ends up going to the middle of
the street you know he brings Lisa with
him he shoots at the bad guy who was
Mathias his gun jams mathias throws the
spear gets him the sun comes up he hands
over his blood he you have to see them
yet like I said Christ metaphor ice
medal year where his blood is gonna save
humanity and also he even dies and
whatever yeah pose like in the fountain
and stuff and never really didn't go out
with like a blaze there should have been
a good shootout scene yeah anti claim is
a little bit anti-climatic if there
weren't that many family members there
should have been a lot more over there
than about 400 of them 500 of them movie
should have ended with a big assault
against his house which is like a castle
he should have like you know machine
gunned a couple of hundred of them and
then they eventually get to him it
should've been something like and he
would've been like overwhelmed by
numbers yeah
but like happens like in some of the
better set pieces on The Walking Dead
where it's raw you can fight a few
zombies but you know there's thousands
of them coming at us by the time the
eighties rolled around they knew how to
end an adventure action movie you know
in the 70s they were still kind of the
pacing is a little strange and I have to
say that I saw the Omega Man a lot when
I was a kid and then I didn't see it for
probably 15 20 years and then I saw it
about three or four years ago and then
we watched it again a couple days ago
and it's weird because it seems like a
different movie every time I watch it
like I don't know if it's because I
forget a lot of what happened like it's
it's kind of like Planet of the Apes
where if you haven't seen it for a long
time like you only remember certain like
iconic scenes yeah and you forget all
the [ __ ] that happened in between the
Oreo filling of the movie as it were and
you know so when you see it again you
kind of forget forgot all that [ __ ] so
you're just like oh yeah this happened
and then there and there's really I feel
like the Omega Man I like the first half
of the movie better yeah when he thinks
he's the only guy he's clueless yeah
he's kind of like I mean it's been three
years right in the context of the movie
better when he's on his own and he's
like talking to himself he's like
playing chess with a bust of Napoleon or
whoever it is yeah the vampires are the
vampire mutants come to his house at
night Sun Devil gonna crawl and and he's
shooting at him with it right infrared
scope on that BA R you know and he's
cruising around an empty Los Angeles
during the day like trying to find these
mutants and stuff he's jogging over dead
people yeah and you know and also the
shots and and actually it's pretty cool
because the shots of LA yeah that they
it's really for 1971 it's pretty creepy
how they got this like every now and
then you'll see a car right there's a
car in the background didn't that they
didn't but they would get but they would
they would clear the streets out to get
that shot they shot they shot it on son
was closed and um you know it wasn't
like you know [ __ ] later movies where
they could just white people out with
CGI or whatever but you know back in
1971 there okay everybody just get off
the street
filming some [ __ ] for anything but yeah
so I definitely liked that more it's
like as this story goes on and you
discover you know and it's kind of cool
like when he meets Lisa these are like
oh here's another person that's been
walking around it that's kind of cool
but like the more you learn that oh now
there's all these other people and
there's all these other survivors it
gets less special I guess yeah because
it's my I mean I know you can't have
just like one dude wandering around no I
still think overall probably better than
Soylent Green yeah now I haven't seen so
I'm like we're gonna see as a kid so
yeah so I'm not gonna make that type of
judgment it's better than the way I
remember Swain green let's say and I saw
something about two years ago and the
thing about Soylent Green too is that a
lot of its iconic status is because of
its twist ending yeah much like playboy
it's kind of like it doesn't have the
same impact and I think I said the same
thing about Planet of the Apes it's like
Nazi oh yeah he was on earth the whole
time I won't think about Omega man
though is that they attribute a lot of
Arnold Schwarzenegger is one-liners that
appear in the 1980s as what was you as
the one the liners that were used in the
Omega Man yeah like they thanks your
cheatin bastard and all that kind of the
whole eighties one-liner damn yeah
everything started we kind of stand from
that no man oh that's interesting yeah I
could kind of see because I'll be back
ya know that kind of [ __ ] senescence
character and it was very kind of Ryan
sort of talking to himself yeah your
moves
Caesar that kind of [ __ ] yeah which is
what would happen like if you die by
yourself for that one hop in yourself
yeah you would of course you would talk
to yourself because you know there'd be
nobody else to talk to
yeah so like I said I kind of liked that
aspect of the movie more and kind of the
same thing happened to with like the
[ __ ] terrible Will Smith version you
know
what is that movie whoa Will Smith cuz
you know I had that movie been written
the right way and done the right way
that would have been a really good movie
well the thing that made me angry one is
that it was essentially just like I said
as I'm a crappy version of 28 days later
you know there were just these
rage-filled running zombie creatures
also okay they shot two endings
evidently the one ending Will Smith
sacrificed himself to save humanity kind
of like happened in the Omega Man that
was the ending that was showed
everywhere else but the us because we
have to have happy endings I guess were
lame and also they shot one where which
is the one that's showed in the US which
is where he gets away right and then
there's like a whole bunch of like a
whole town and yeah humanity is a
problem like I said the problem with
Will Smith will get lucky say what well
no like I said that that's the whole
point of the book yeah is that the main
character is supposed to be a monster
it's supposed to be like a twist
starting exactly none of the movies
really get that except for a last man on
earth I'm gonna give you my attack on
Will Smith's I am Legend the problem
with it was two major things first of
all it was not a global pandemic it was
just an outbreak in a city that really
ruined it any kind of feelings of
isolation that that Neville has to have
it was just the same yes it wasn't a
local band and they were talking to him
on radio so he wasn't alone that was the
one thing that they did wrong second
thing that they did wrong is that the
mutants couldn't talk yeah so there you
go the coolest things about the Omega
Man and last man on earth and the
original iron legends is that the the
so-called vampires could talk they were
characters in the story and you know
you're supposed to be able to say you
see things from their eyes too so they
just dumped them down to like rage
zombies that ran around it that was the
whole point is that you were supposed to
flip the perspective around because the
whole movie or just think these mutants
vampires whatever we're bad guys but
from their perspective Neville was the
bag yeah
the last men on earth and he was a
monster yeah you know that's I mean that
was what the whole point of the book was
and like I said they did do that in last
man on earth cannot send macho Megaman
but yeah that was one of the problems
the minor problems of the Omega Man is
it didn't show Neville's campaign of
extermination against the family and I
think so they so he didn't have the
monstrous quality that the family the
audience didn't get the monstrous
qualities of Neville you know because
they didn't see what the family went
through they should have had a lot of
scenes with Neville just [ __ ] him up
with flamethrowers and bombs yeah
machine gun and hundreds of them are
dozens of them you know because it
should be noted that in the book now in
every iteration of this novel Neville is
always portrayed as a scientist usually
a scientist that was working on
something you know akin to that yeah in
the book he was not a scientist he was
just a guy guy figured and he just
figured he figured out the biological
agent that had caused the plague and
things like that but he only wanted the
information about the plague so he could
more effectively kill the vampires he
wasn't really trying to cure them right
he just wanted to file for a ways of
wiping them out I have hopes that one
day a better version of Omega Man will
appear now I am Legend not yeah and last
man on earth but a reboot of Omega Man
and the way I would do it is it would be
something along the lines of Mad Max it
would be a post-apocalyptic story he's
the last man on earth he's doing a
campaign of extermination on these damn
vampire like mutants and now there's a
lot you could do a lot of that story
yeah he might gonna make two or three
movies of that well one guy alone using
all these survival tactics making his
own fortresses you know death mobiles
that kind of stuff
yeah man it'd be kind of like a zombie
movie but there would be vampires they
could talk they think he's a monster and
he's the last of his kind
you know I mean that's they can't use
technology and he's using technology and
he spends all of his time being kind of
like a one-man demolition crew almost
kind of like a reverse Mont almost like
a zombie movie
but as if you were the only put one left
and you were the monster and like a
zombies were normal that's why the first
part of Omega man is the more
effectively creepy to me because you
think that he's the only person left on
earth all these mutants and stuff like
that
which is way scarier than oh I just went
down the street and found some people
right you know what I mean and it's kind
of its kind of more alienating and
scarier than say like fear to Walking
Dead where there are groups of survivors
yeah you know fighting zombies in the
Omega man there's like you're only one
guy yeah because you have to think to
yourself what the [ __ ] it's you know
it's kind of like a desert island
scenario you're like the only person
like how long would it take you to go
crazy and sever up that but you know you
have the added you know detail of like
all these monsters that are like
actively trying to kill you and they can
talk yeah they have their own culture
intelligencer and they're trying to
basically wipe you out right now one of
the things and I should say this I'm
going to have a little bit of a
criticism one of the things that I
didn't like about the Omega man is that
like I said it's been three years I'm
guessing since the plague spread and
since everybody died and evidently these
mutants have been trying to kill
Charlton Heston's character for a long
time yes now yes he is in a three-story
building he's got the elevator all
locked down and stuff like that's you
can't get in through the lower floors
kind of converted into a miner and he's
caught yeah it's kind of like a fortress
and stuff like that but the thing is the
mutants have catapults like with
fireballs in him and [ __ ] like that and
Charlton Heston he lives up on the third
floor it looks like he stole like all
the fine art from every Museum it was
kind of funny
maybe the hockey paradise yeah I mean a
hockey paradise he's got all the best
Scotch like Stockton which we would do
you know I don't blame him for that yeah
but he doesn't like close the upper
windows he just said you know he likes
to go out on his balcony and stuff like
that you would think that like I said
the mutants had a catapult that they
would have burned that [ __ ] down yeah
what time ago
time they throw a little fireball in
there use the catapult and it does catch
the curtains on fires but he just uses a
fire put it out many shoots out of a
couple times get out of here never yes
but that's what I mean see here's the
thing - they never really showed
Charlton Heston sleeping so like when is
asleep cuz like evidently he goes out
during the day he goes to the movies
kills mutants but then at night he
defends his palace he defends the house
but you would have to because it's a at
night yeah
then attack your house I mean you can't
sleep because they can save your [ __ ] on
fire and it would burn down with you in
there you would have you would think
that Neville would be would be also be
nocturnal doctor that would have to be
because you know otherwise they could
sneak up cuz like late in the movie you
know the the lieutenant of the mutants
yeah he basically just climbs up the
side of the hat which he could have done
it anytime yeah he had a grappling hook
farm ever yeah he could have done that
whenever another thing is is that the
mutants aka the vampires would want to
call they can't use modern technology
but they allow themselves to use
medieval technology yeah I can't go that
far so if he's in a fortress why don't
they just use a siege tower that's
medieval technology yeah you could just
roll it up at the house roll it up to
the house climb up the stairs the siege
Tower jump on his roof yeah soon as you
can on roof you got it yeah and you
think they would have known about that
they had plenty of wood plenty of time
you know there was yeah he's got a lot
of guns but you got to run out of ammo
sometime yeah yeah well no actually if
you're the last man on earth oh that's
true [ __ ] yeah he can only and that's
the thing too like I see this is I
always put myself in scenarios and like
people in these movies if I was Charlton
Heston which I am not obviously and I
was the last person on earth and I was
being pursued by mutants and stuff like
that it's like you know I can see how he
likes his house and he doesn't want to
move and stuff like that I would just
leave yeah I would just leave has had
good guns though he had he had a var
with a infrared night scope on it
he had an mp40 at MK 760 yeah he had
k760 I saw that and looked like to mp4
T's and I think he had a Browning m2 v
yeah I think that might have been
another movie I think he had that up
there on tripod on his balcony yeah I'm
not sure I think he there was but yeah
so that was you know it's just hard for
me to suspend hospitals yeah that's all
I'm saying is because there was a lot I
mean it was just one of him and there
was a lot of budgetary restrictions of
the time so you know you could do that
you could redo that movie today or just
be awesome well do a lot of dead yeah I
mean if somebody like with half a brain
I there they need to make a good remake
for Omega and I would also still like to
see a good and faithful adaptation of
the novel because there has not been one
like I said last on earth is pretty
close to the book
why don't you rewrite Omega Man what the
license cost for Omega Man I don't know
to be honest I'm surprised they haven't
remade it because I think it's good
series it would yes I'm surprised I save
it because there's so much like
post-apocalyptic sup people in writing
wait a half's man I could play devil a
ka that no answering the crustle spirit
work on the movie just so I can be
deeper into the crystal spear have you
doing something you got this all figured
it all figured out anyway yeah so if you
like 1970s horror sci-fi thriller sci fi
thriller inamorata kind of stuff and if
you want to see kind of where the whole
post-apocalyptic zombie thing of today
kind of had its roots and stuff like
that well first thing I'd recommend
reading Richard Matheson's book because
it's really good it's not very long
well man on earth but also yeah see last
man on earth of Vincent Price that's
actually my favorite a lot of people
don't like so it's boring and stuff like
that's an honor I think is on Netflix it
might be in it wasn't interesting but
yeah so that's the closest to the book
but the Omega man like I said it's like
a really cool if you like Soylent Green
like Planet of the Apes any of those
kind of even Logan's Ron if you like
that kind of stuff that
around that time then you'll probably
dig this although I'm just like a
throwback sci-fi there's somebody save
for it it's from a simpler time yeah it
does have its own message well it has
its own charm
it's very of its time too because
there's all this stuff about Woodstock
and black power like the whole culture
clash but he's a counter counterculture
just another part of the problem with
sci-fi today's they're trying to make
too much sense when you're making too
much sense it doesn't have enough
strength and wisdom to violate logic and
honestly I don't know if you can get
away with it nowadays you could get away
with it backers that [ __ ] are too
smart man you well that's why because I
think people were one I think people
were a lot less critical back in there
they'd be like oh yeah that was I
supposed to run you know what I mean
they just kind of got my head I remember
my dad called [ __ ] on that [ __ ]
though you can barely say these people
was that if movies were about fun yeah
you see a weird-ass situation have fun
looking at go what I would do is I'd do
this it's that kind of stuff yeah maybe
everyone's to analytically to
analytically nitpick [ __ ] too much
Internet yeah that's true yeah I feel
like I don't well I don't know okay I
can't really say that I don't do that
because honestly unless a movie like
actively insults my intelligence like I
will generally roll with it unless it
just gets so aggressively stupid that I
can't take it anymore I can roll with
doom because I read the movie I know
what the movies trying to having read
the book so I know what the movies
trying to say
yeah but making a movie about dune is
kind of like making a movie about the
book of Genesis out of the Bible you
can't make a movie about Jesus what you
mean is too many characters yeah Joey
characters too convoluted Joey
convoluted well you know you imagine you
trying to take the book of Genesis and
make it an hour and a half long movie
you can't that's what they try to do
with doom yeah dune is unmovable they
can do a series I bet you can do a
series but it'd have to look like De
Laurentiis is like kidding yeah they got
the look and honestly I love David Lynch
but the but dune I can't it it does not
make any sense man I read the book too
but that was like a long time ago I have
no [ __ ] idea what's going on
talk about you but I can't it's hard for
me to sit through because I'm just like
what why I don't know and I like weird
[ __ ] I like you know cuz it [ __ ] doesn't
have to make sense it's fine I have roll
with it dial every bit of dialogue got a
dune is like the pontiff occations and
statements that you would see how the
Old Testament yeah yeah that's true
and thus it has begun the sleeper has
awakened yes Tim you know Jabbar nobody
it's just kind of like nobody in dude
just like I guess nobody in the Bible
ever is just like chill no they never
say it's always so you bring me beer
it's almost like a religious statement
the spice must flow yeah everything has
to have this ominous you know portentous
uh no car even Shakespeare characters
made of art jokes but we're talking
about doing a Rondo megohm a video that
shut it down Jenny dude you do already
down all right shut that [ __ ] down
you got any [ __ ] pants yeah I got a
symphony I hope you enjoyed this bout we
[ __ ] ramble all the time this
rambling review they think a man with
the saddest Saturday it's sadder we're
not even drunk I'm not a caffeinated and
that's about it okay but yeah so uh
awesome oh yeah we'll work something out
about being drunk yeah alright let's
turn this [ __ ] up go get to work on that
alright so I just remember check out our
patreon check out our blog check out all
our other [ __ ] on Facebook Twitter yadda
yadda and we will see you next time bye